i
promise you that i will not sing i will
spare you that at least
but i am a historian
with a background in philosophy
and my main area of research is
basically the history of southeast asia
with a focus on 19th century colonial
southeast asia
and over the last few years what i've
been doing what i've been doing
is really tracing the history of certain
ideas
that shape our viewpoint the way we in
asia and southeast asia look at
ourselves and understand ourselves
now there's one
thing that i cannot explain as a
historian
and this has been puzzling me for for a
long time
and this is how and why
certain ideas certain viewpoints
do not seem to ever go away
and i don't know why and in particular
i'm interested to understand
why some people not all by by no means
but
some people um in postcolonial
asia still hold on to a somewhat
romanticized
view of the colonial past
see through a kind of rose tinted lenses
as perhaps a time that was benevolent or
nice or pleasant even though historians
know the realities of the violence
and the oppression and the dark side of
that entire colonial experience so let's
imagine
i built a time machine for myself
i build a time machine and i send myself
back to
the 1860s 100 years before
i was born oh yeah i've just dated
myself
okay i go back a hundred years before i
was born
now if i were to find myself in the
context of colonial southeast asia in
the 19th century
i would not be a professor historians
know this
and yet despite that
there's still some quarters that somehow
want to hold on to this idea that that
past
was not as murky that there were
a romanticized side to it now here is
where i
as a historian i encounter the limits of
history
because i can trace ideas i can
find out the origins of certain cliches
certain stereotypes i can tell you who
came up with it
where and when and in which book but
that's one thing i cannot do
i cannot get into the internal
subjective
mental universe of someone and change
their mind
and i think this is where and why over
the last few years i'm
increasingly drawn to things like
psychology
and cognitive behavioral therapy because
in these fields
scholars look at the persistence of
ideas why do some people have certain
prejudices why are there certain biases
certain phobias you know
we live unfortunately sadly in a world
where still
you know misogyny persists racism
persists
all kinds of phobia islamophobia for
instance is now a term
and why do these ideas persist and
many scholars agree that it's partly
because when looking at the world we
fall back we fall back we fall back
on a finite pool a small pool of basic
ideas that don't get
challenged look at how we particularly
us in
south east asia represent
ourselves to ourselves and to the world
look at how
often when we talk about ourselves oh my
viewpoint my identity our identity
invariably we fall back we fall back we
fall back we fall back
on the same set of ideas all of which
have
histories of their own
very simple example we live in southeast
asia
which is very popular with tourists from
all over the world
and i don't think that's a bad thing by
the way you know i think it's
good that the tourists come to southeast
asia because it's part and parcel of
broadening your
view and meeting cultures etc etc but
look at how we represent ourselves
through the tourist campaigns the
tourist ads that we produce
there will be the obligatory coconut
tree banana tree
and the orangutan doesn't even get paid
right
look at how we represent ourselves look
at how we represent
nature look at how we represent the
countryside look at how we represent
agricultural life watch our sitcoms
watch our dramas watch our movies it's
very common particularly in southeast
asia when you watch these uh
sitcoms if there's someone from the
countryside
inferibly they're ugly
they're funny they're silly they're
without knowledge
it's as if the countryside has nothing
to offer our view of nature
despite all our talk despite all our
talk about
asian philosophy asian values
despite all our talk about how you know
we have a
organic relationship to nature how do we
actually treat nature in southeast asia
today
we regard nature as something to be
defeated
and exploited and that's the reality
so the way in which we live in our part
of the world post-colonial southeast
asia in so many ways
for me bears
residual traces to ideas
tropes cliches stereotypes that have a
history
this idea of the countryside as a place
to be exploited
the idea of country folk as being
without knowledge
these ideas that historians like me can
go back we can trace
how these stereotypes emerged and they
emerged
at a time when southeast asia
was being governed according to the
logic of colonial capitalism
and in so many ways we've taken these
ideas with us
they're part of us now but we are not
critical in interrogating ourselves and
asking ourselves how did i have
this view of the world how did i come to
have this view of nature how did i come
to have this view of the countryside
how do i have this idea of asia as
exotic and we
saw these asians in particular love
to self-exoticize ourselves you know
we've turned southeast asian identity
into a kind of
cosplay you know where you can literally
go to the supermarket to go to the mall
and
and buy your do-it-yourself exotic
southeast asian costume kit
and we parade this identity not asking
ourselves
how and when did this particular image
of ourselves emerge they all have a
history to it
and that's why increasingly as a
historian
i find that as i encounter the limits of
history i see
that i can't work alone anymore
i can't work alone anymore because
there's absolutely no point
in me doing my archival work there's no
point in me
seeking the roots of these ideas tracing
the genesis of ideas and then putting it
in some journal to be read by maybe
three other historians there's
absolutely no point
the reason why i think this is important
is because
our region southeast asia will i believe
in the years to come go through enormous
changes
unprecedented changes in our history
partly because of globalization
world politics geopolitical
contestations
the impact of technology the fourth
industrial revolution
our world as we know it is going to
change
but for us to adapt to this change for
us to be ready for that change we need
to think
out of the box and we can't fall back
and we can't fall back we can't fall
back on the same
set of cliched tired
state all stereotypes we need to think
out and that's why historians we can't
work alone now
i i need to engage with
people in psychology people in
behavioral therapy i need to engage with
sociologists anthropologists political
economists i need above all
to engage with people in the arts and
the media
because it's there in that forum outside
the confines of the university that
these debates really
need to take place and they need to take
place
now because we need to
understand that things the way things
are today
are not determined by some fixed
iron historical railway track but rather
there are many other histories many
other ideas that were forgotten
marginalized erased
along the line historians like me our
job is to uncover all this
discover all this but we need to engage
this we need to engage
with society as a whole so to go back
to that time machine example i gave
earlier
let's say this is a 19th century
colonial subject then and the person's
wondering
will empire ever come to an end will
there be an end to all this will
we one day be free so the person invents
a time machine
goes into the future and arrives here in
post-colonial southeast asia
today another person looks around
and the person will say oh yes indeed
the imperial flags are gone
the imperial gunboats are gone the
colonial armies are gone there are new
flags new nation states
there is independence after all but has
there been
the person then watches
the tourist ads and sees again the
banana tree the coconut tree and the
orangutan
the person watches some tv
and watches how images of an exotic
southeast asia are being reproduced
again and again
by southeast asians and the person might
then come to the conclusion that well
notwithstanding the fact that
colonialism is over we are still
in so so many ways
living in the long shadow of the 19th
century
and this i think has has become
my personal mission the reason why i
think history is so important and the
reason why i think it's so important for
history to go
beyond history because we need to
reignite this debate about who and what
we are
all of us we talk about oh my i have my
viewpoint you have your viewpoint well
that's partly true our viewpoints
are never entirely our own individually
we are all social beings we are
historical beings you me
all of us we carry history in us it's in
the language we use
it's in the fiction we write it's in the
movies we choose to watch it's in the
images that we conjure when we think of
who and what we are
we are historical beings we carry
history with us and history carries us
along
but while we are determined by history
it is my personal belief
that we need not be trapped by history
and we need not be the victims of
history
thank you